[Musique]
j'aime la France j'aime en public
c'était
primordial et révocable de partir à Los
Angeles de pouvoir
tu réussis
[Musique]
écoutez c'était quand même plus marrant
de me voir déranger dans la rue à des
moments où il fallait pas plutôt que la
gentillesse dont
me font par la plupart des gens enfin
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt agréable
mais là on a évidemment appuyé là où ça
fait mal mais c'est vrai que c'est
pesant pour vous par moment de pas
pouvoir sortir tranquillement dans la
rue en fait bizarrement je sais pas si
c'était rapide si c'est la série qui m'a
réconcilié avec ça mais en fait
maintenant j'ai beaucoup de gratitude
pour ce qui m'arrive et j'accepte avec
beaucoup de bonheur tout
d'être dérangé en fait ça fait partie du
jeu et c'est pas très grave par rapport
à tout l'amour qu'on reçoit c'est un
bonheur